Perfekte Illusionen
- allesamt entstanden auf dem Körper
von Mirjana Milosevic, genannt Kika.
Millionen Menschen aus
der ganzen Welt
klicken sich zurzeit auf die immer
neuen Kunstwerke der Serbin.
In ihrer Wohnung in Smederevo,
50 Kilometer von Belgrad entfernt,
hat sie sich ein kleines Atelier eingerichtet.
Ständig produziert sie neue Videos.
Schon als Kind hat sie gern gezeichnet,
die Malerei hat sie sich selber beigebracht.
Ihr besonderes Markenzeichen sind
optische Täuschungen.
Ich liebe Herausforderungen,
deshalb habe ich beschlossen,
mich auf optische
Täuschungen zu spezialisieren.
Es ist einfach lustig,
wenn man sich einen Knoten in
den Bauch macht oder was auch immer.
Es macht mir einfach Spaß, denn
jeden Tag bin ich jemand anderes.
Erst vor gut einem Jahr startete die
35-Jährige ihren eigenen Videokanal.
Mit diesem Bodypainting als Holzpuppe
gewann sie 2016 in Serbien
eine wichtige Auszeichnung in
der Maskenbildner-Szene.
Das war ihr internationaler Durchbruch.
Mehr als 130.000 Menschen haben
ihren Youtube-Kanal abonniert
und verfolgen regelmäßig ihre
neuen Videos - für sie ein Traum.
Ich bin so glücklich. Ich habe Kontakt
zu Menschen auf der ganzen Welt.
Und wenn sie mir schreiben: „Küsse aus
Brasilien“ oder „Küsse aus Frankreich“,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, als wäre ich
schon dort gewesen oder als sei ich dort.
Das ist ein ganz besonderes Gefühl.
Mittlerweile kann die zweifache Mutter
von ihrem Videokanal leben.
Rund zwei neue Filme postet sie pro Woche,
ständig bekommt sie Rückmeldungen
von überall her, auch auf Spanisch.
Du bist so außergewöhnlich in
dem, was du machst.
Du überraschst mich jedes Mal aufs Neue.
Ich wünsche dir alles Gute und mach
weiter so.
Vielen Dank, Freundin.
Mehr als vier Millionen Menschen
haben alleine dieses Video angeklickt,
Kika kann ihren Erfolg immer
noch nicht so recht fassen.
Ich denke jedes Mal: Was ist,
wenn die Leute es nicht mögen?
Und was ist, wenn sie‘s mögen?
Und wenn das Video dann hochgeladen
ist, dann kann ich gar nicht hinschauen.
Dann sage ich immer zu meinen
Kollegen und Freunden:
Könnt Ihr mir bitte nur die
guten Kommentare vorlesen?
Zwei Tage bereitet sie ihre Motive vor,
guckt sich im Spiegel an,
was passen könnte und
was nicht. Und sie findet:
Ein Knoten im Bauch passt irgendwie zu ihr.
Bis zu acht Stunden arbeitet sie
an ihren jeweiligen Kunstwerken.
Inspirieren lässt sie sich durch Musik
oder durch ihre ganz eigenen Erfahrungen.
Ich hatte ein Problem mit meinem Gewicht.
Ich konnte nicht essen,
ich hatte keinen Appetit.
Und das fühlte sich für mich so an,
als hätte ich einen Knoten im Bauch.
Erst mit dieser schwarzen Hintergrundwand
werden die optischen Täuschungen perfekt.
Das Kniffelige ist für die
Maskenbildnerin außerdem,
ständig beim Malen die Luft
anzuhalten, sonst verwackelt das Bild.
Und ein bisschen Zauberei ist
auch immer mit im Spiel.
Hokuspokus, Abrakadabra:
Und ich habe einen Knoten im Bauch.
Doch die Illusionskünstlerin zaubert
nicht nur Knoten in ihren Bauch,
sondern auch andere Formen
wie diese Spirale.
Sie gehört zu dem
Holzpuppen-Bodypainting
und war für Kika die
größte Herausforderung.
Diese Spirale hat mir so
viele Probleme bereitet,
denn es ist irre schwer, auf dem Bauch zu
malen. Auf der Haut des Bauches.
Denn du darfst dich nicht bewegen,
wenn du am Ende ein
perfektes Bild haben möchtest.
Mit ihren perfekten Körpergemälden
verfolgt Kika ein ganz großes Ziel.
Mein Traum ist es, eines Tages auf
dem roten Teppich zu stehen
und den Oscar in der Hand zu halten.
Bevor es soweit ist, produziert sie aber
noch weiterhin Make-up Kunstwerke
und Tutorials für ihre Fans.
Immerhin:
Auch US-Schauspieler Charly Sheen
hat schon eines ihrer Videos geteilt.
Vielleicht schafft Kika es ja am Ende,
mit ihrer Kunst ein bisschen
über sich hinauszuwachsen und
dabei nicht den Kopf zu verlieren.